so first questioner there is quite a bit
on parametric's in this quiz because
parametric's is a tough topic you get
given parametric equations here aid here
which I've chosen to number you didn't
have to number them it just makes it
easier to communicate what you're doing
and how your equations interact if you
do so that's why I've called them I've
called the question 1 and equation 2 so
once I do that to form the Cartesian
equation what I'm trying to do is
eliminate the parameter trying to
eliminate the parameter so that's why
the very first thing that I do is make
the parameter the subject of one of the
equations so I can substitute it into
the other then the parameter is gone you
can see it's much easier to do that with
equation 1 that equation 2 so that's why
I rearranged and there is my
substitution so are you okay with 12x
squared thumbs-up great
now admittedly well let me I should ask
this how many people got question -
heads up straight okay a small number
this happens right sometimes a question
is early on and it just stops you right
so typical exam technique don't get
intimidated just move on and come back
in if you have the title see here you go
now let's have a look at the question
because as you can see my solution there
it might not be the solution that came
to mind just for people who did get it
so do I have some agreement yes no maybe
looking good okay so what did I do for
what those of be is this line tangent to
this curve okay now because it's y
equals x cubed you run into a problem
we've looked at questions like this
before and if you have a look at the
excuse me at the question beneath this
is how questions like this often play
out I'll come back to solution in a
minute but when you want things to be
tangent often what you do is you make
the discriminate to be equal to zero
right you see that before you solve
simultaneously you make the discriminate
equal to zero but you can't do that with
this curve why not yeah why can't use
the discriminate here
what what kind of equation does the
discriminant relate to fig fig I'm
waiting for it you guys know the answer
this you only use the discriminant when
it's what kind of equation it's a
quadratic right and when you try and
solve this simultaneously
you've got next cute flag there right so
that's no use to you so I have to try
some other kind of approach so here's
what I thought here's what I drew there
we go
in blue I've got my y equals x cubed
curve okay and in green what I'm trying
to visualize is y equals I should write
it down for you y equals 12x plus B now
what this means is you've got the
gradient locked in right that's what the
12x tells you it's a very steep line but
B is variable so that means your graph
can move up and down does that make
sense so this version here could slide
upwards to translate and you would get
the same it's still y equals 12x plus B
just a different value of B now once you
can see that you could immediately see
from this very rough drawing there's
gonna be two solutions does that make
sense like I don't know what they are
yet but I know they were going to be two
okay because Solek simultaneously gives
you this equation right you're kind of
like I can't do very much with this it's
a cubic after all you can't put it to
the formula you can't use the
discriminant so therefore you need some
other kind of tool which is why this
topic is what topic that we're in right
now right now what's it called
well we're we're doing really badly
today come on guys we can name the topic
this is geometrical applications of
calculus right so I'm using
differentiation to my advantage so
that's why the first thing I do over
here is I differentiate okay so you can
see what I've done is I've found the
gradient of the curve and of course it's
variable because it's the cubic cursor
changes all along but the gradient of
the line isn't going to change it's
always 12 you see that it's always 12 so
I want if it gonna be really tangent
then somewhere along this cubic curve
its gradient I see at 12 in fact it's
gonna be twice right there's two I
showed you before so once you've got
that you say well let the
credit function equal that particular
gradient you get some solutions out of
that right because x squared equals 4 so
here are my two values okay but you're
not other words yet what this tells you
is this is where that's going to occur
at negative two and that's going to
occur positive that's a bad scale but
you get the idea okay
so this tells you where you're going to
have pages but it doesn't tell you what
those tangents are so therefore I've got
to do a little more work what I have to
find is okay well where do those pages
intersect so I did that right and
there's two solutions you notice this
when you go ahead and you put them into
X cubed you'll find two different
coordinates and then to get the
equations in straight lines to find B
I've got to substitute it into those
equations of those straight lines to
better evaluate okay so does that make
sense you see how I there's quite a lot
of thinking that goes into that you got
to really understand how to use the
derivative not just go through a rule
and crunch it does that make sense all
right
question three in comparison was
relatively straightforward so it's even
been given to you in general form which
is convenient so I just had to go b
squared minus 4ac the discriminant calls
0 for equal roots and so I've got
negative 6 or 2 so I have some nods
shakes yes no looking good okay all
right yeah question
where are you looking at sorry what am i
done which which light are you talking
about are you talking about this spot
here yes so remember this is B squared
right
so there's be right there but once you
square it if you square something this
side doesn't matter so that's why I
haven't written it because you're still
going to get K squared plus K plus 16y a
negative sides are really your thing
thinner right watch out for those so
yeah there you go okay so then what
comes next is question 4 and there are
obviously many parts the question for so
let's start off with the easy one okay
you're just looking for f of X equals
zero one of those when f of x equals
zero you're gonna get intercept right so
I find my intercepts because of course
this guide here is X minus three X plus
three so I've got my two x-intercepts
there so it looks good I'm gonna just
funnel them back at the back of my mind
then this is what we've been working on
most recently so hopefully you start to
get into a bit of a rhythm here I've
differentiated right here and then I've
instinctively factorized why did I do
that for
why don't wire my factorizing because
I'm gonna solve I'm gonna solve for what
what am i solving I'm solving for the
coordinates of what for the Koretz of X
for when y what am I going toward I'm
looking for stationary points so I want
the derivative to be equal zero and I
can find that most easiest when it's
bead factorized like so okay it's very
easy to read off I've got this solution
and this solution okay you can see oh
I'm missing some working this sorry that
should say y equals you can see I
immediately work out my coordinates why
do I do that just have a look at the
question have a look at the question
come on point you to the answer to this
I'm waiting for an answer why am i
finding the coordinates why do I go
straight to Y
cuz cuz the question says find the
coordinates that's why just read the
question okay once you've got those I
still need to determine their nature you
can see the path that I've gone down I
failed the second derivative why did I
do that for go rewind I chose the second
derivative I chose the second derivative
because I could do the first derivative
but it's easy to differentiate this
thing it's a polynomial
super simple no questions or anything
like that and the reason for that was
because I wanted to determine the nature
please don't skip on this part here
please say state the concavity that's
really important will you lose marks for
that maybe maybe not but you should
state your own sanity of what's going on
like you know what a positive second
derivative means it's about concavity up
or down so I got my relative max got my
relative minimum and then here's my
graph now I'll tell you a are cheeky
little secret when I drew this right how
did I get my curve looking so good did I
use a temple or something like that no I
don't have a template for that curve I
just I just drew the curve I knew what
rough shape was gonna have because it's
got a max it's gonna be once I drew the
curve roughly I just put the axes on top
wherever I do they were going to be
right I knew that I wanted for example I
knew that the y-intercept was going to
be negative 27 how did I do that
I think it's in the original equation
right all the way up here I expanded you
see that that's where I expanded so I
know what my y-intercept is going to be
and I've found just down here I found
what my Y coordinates of my stationary
point gonna be so negative 27 negative
32
I know they are in the same vicinity so
therefore you see I positioned them next
to each other and I place my y-axis
where it belongs does that make sense
I probably could improve my scale a
little bit but you get the idea okay and
then the rest of it is there any
questions about that does that make
sense for what values of the graph of
the graph of y equals f of X is y of X
concave down you can see I've just
solved for where the second derivative
is negative so
value okay it's worth doing a quick
sense check for that because you just
drew the graph you just drew the graph
you can know in that's right yeah x is
less than negative what where's that
gonna be negative ones somewhere around
here yeah so does it look concave down
on the left hand side does it look at
here it does right look concave down
concave down concave down so what you've
found is the point of inflection
I haven't proven that it's the point of
inflection but the question did not ask
me to do that so that's why I don't go
any further I'd do a neighborhood test
does that make sense okay